should we establish a safe word yeah I'm
consenting this is fun
they're saying no that's so embarrassing
Joyride
every single person who's important is
here I'm Sabrina wool I'm Sherry Cola
and I'm Ashley Park and our Oscar
nominee Stephanie Shu rushed to a flight
she's on her way to an airport or at the
airport she's flying the plane Delta
569. you guys release from the bottle
once I was really pure as a child and
when the kids started playing I
literally got up and said I'm leaving
who's with me did anyone come no
I was like first kisses mean something
to me and so on walked out yeah
it's not really about kissing we're
essentially playing truth or dare also
We're Not Gonna Kiss
okay truth or down cheers tell us your
celebrity crush uh Obama oh yeah oh
great
I'll just go for it
so since it pointed to not us three
we're gonna call Steph
she didn't actually have the help in
Flight she went to oh my God Stephanie
you're in your bedroom so Truth or Dare
Stephanie shoe
no you look fantastic when was the last
time you cried thinking of looking
fantastic the last time I cried honestly
was yesterday when that 70 year old man
started to tell us that he watched our
movie and that the thing that he loved
the most was the first scene where the
two kids are on the playground and one
of
punches the white kid because he called
her a ching chong and he was saying how
how much that resonated with him and he
was like that was my life that happened
to me I was in Chinatown my friend
punched that kid and then in the same
two minutes after I was uh weeping he
also said and you know I used to have a
girlfriend who looked like you and she
loved the d-i-c-k
I remember that story and that was very
special
we might call you again we actually
might call you yeah we might call you
again Truth or Dare I'll do it there
yeah audition for another person's role
in Joyride
okay a cat
I am a good Christian girl
me and Clarence have a spiritual not
physical connection
did I Ash Truth or Dare truth what's
your biggest hot take I think Mayo
tastes good on everything okay
okay I'll take you out I'm gonna reverse
that
you oh wait what do you want I actually
haven't done one
show us a hidden talent what this guy
you should go to Vegas with us what
about this
you get the point okay ready
Sabrina or Ashley it's technically
Ashley
um I'll take a truth rake your co-stars
by Riz level I think rizz it's Gotta Go
are you gonna be okay if I'm last I'll
tell you no no I'm last why I think
Stephen sharer tied at the top and you
know I think you're just like a question
at the bottom oh I will take it I think
we're all pretty Rizzy in different ways
Rizzy McGuire no I had a question I had
a crush on a guy for the first time in a
long time and then Steph saw that and
was like okay well why don't I see how
I'm doing and she did let's not exposed
because she can't defend herself sorry
well I mean all I'm saying is that stuff
has great RIS and um ice definitely a
worse Rose okay oh oh okay we'll just
get some spins okay Truth or Dare I'll
do dare passionately profess your love
for the spinner I love you Sherry I love
you so much I love you I don't love you
so much oh that's nice I love you thank
you oh wow is that passionate enough yes
that was very good I'm overwhelmed
slap the spinner with the tortilla this
is so interesting this dare is like
awesome for me but I guess hard for you
well you don't do a good slap that's
embarrassing for you oh okay well I'll
give you a good slap this is them
settling their competitors I love being
a comfortable second place which is
great because Sabrina plays to conquer
that's not true I'm I just I'm there for
a good time but come here
this is we're taking longest road
oh
this is fun Should we establish a safe
word well I think that if I say the word
it'll be too late okay close your eyes
wait but don't move me with your hands
it'll be over before
oh did you want it oh nice little slab
yeah do harder come on oh oh my God okay
can you just hold my hand
nice I feel alive
now we know I kind of want the thrill
I'll do it
oh my God that's your heart
[Music]
that sounds
wait are you okay
oh you're so sweet for not
are you sure that sounds
look I can't believe it wait kind of
light
um
Ashley Truth or Dare let's go back to
truth next one is gonna jump off a
building
who would you add to the cast if there
was a joy ride too I like that one oh
Bon Yang dead eyes brother or I keep
pushing to be recast
that's what it was a place
um
tell us the story of your worst date I
actually don't have one of those
no dates though like that's it I can
actually that's what that was a pretty
terrible date if you get ghosted because
there's no date
the worst date I had was when the date
didn't show up I think the worst date on
the lunar calendar okay just give me a
dare get a mouthful of water while your
co-stars attempt to make you laugh love
it
please
[Laughter]
sharing
just hydrate
we're family we're family well that
sounds too
what move your TV show is your biggest
guilty pleasure uh maybe Pretty Little
Liars me too wait original or spin-off
original wow respect who do you think is
the hottest of the four Originals okay I
have to pass okay get the penalty Jordan
yeah there's been off questions here
that's how we roll the penalty drawer
take a pickle shot this is pickle juice
fruit yeah but
this is not a shot this is no just take
a little sip like after you know a jog
oh how's it oh
oh okay extra points okay now keep the
pickle juice in your mouth while we make
you laugh is it good yeah I love pickle
juice I haven't had it recreationally
what's the pickle pickle book shop what
is called pickle book pickle back shot
it's like Jameson and then you chase it
with the pickle
one more Truth or Dare what's the last
thing you Googled let's go this is stuff
that makes my nipples hard this is your
phone case it changed because the other
one broke ah
yeah
it's always tough you know how last
night my dress was shrinky stringy so I
went home I got back to my hotel and
then there was literally uh toothpick
stuck to my dress and I thought it was
really disgusting and funny uh thank you
BuzzFeed I think we've learned that
we're all the chaotic ones yeah um
totally surprisingly strong with rizz
joy ride in theaters July 7th everywhere
mwah
[Music]